it is an understatement to say that a
lot has happened in the past year but
who are the transformative figures who
have impacted and shaped 2017 that's a
question bloomberg businessweek sought
to answer in a new special issue out now
a large group of bloomberg journalists
put their heads together to come up with
the first annual Bloomberg 50 some of
the figures are in the news right now
such as special counsel Robert Muller
others are household names such as Tesla
CEO Elon Musk the list includes
entertainment figures like Wonder Woman
director patty Jenkins and those noted
for their humanitarian work including
Nobel Peace Prize recipient the etre
spin to break down other names on the
list we welcome Brett begin an editor at
Bloomberg Businessweek who helped to
compile the list Brett thanks for
joining us yeah you're welcome let's
start with a man who is on many lists
but that does not diminish his reasons
for being on those lists Jeff Bezos yeah
Jeff Bezos hard to argue that he didn't
have a massive year On June 16th of this
year decides to drop 13.7 billion
dollars on wholefoods really what he did
in doing that is essentially signal to
the world that he doesn't want Amazon
just to be the biggest online retailer
in the world but the biggest retailer in
the world and within hours of that
announcement the Walmarts of the world
Costco's the program's lost a combined
30 billion dollars Wow
speaking of Amazon another name on the
list helped develop Amazon's Alexa
technology tell us about Geoffrey Hinton
yeah Geoffrey Hinton is really a
fascinating guy he's considered the
godfather of AI in many ways he invented
something that is called the neural net
and if you used Amazon Alexa if you've
watched as Facebook identified your
friends photos or if we use autopilot on
Tesla that's actually all goes back to
research he did and Canada this year
opened up a nearly 200 million dollar
Institute to be able to keep him there
and other aai experts in Canada and when
Hinton started that research it was kind
of dismissed as and this isn't gonna go
anywhere right this is the mid seventies
late 70s and people that sort of said
you know what neural nets
they're kind of done there's really not
much of a future here and then this
thing called the internet came along and
it turned out that you could actually
program these neural nets with a ton
more information and lo and behold all
of the big tech firms decided hey we
need more different ins out there well
we do okay a lot another person that
readers may not be familiar with Diane
Greene when has her contribution been
right Diane Greene is Google's cloud
chief and Google's cloud business grew
about 80 percent year-over-year
and while Google only has a very small
portion of the cloud business Amazon
really is the giant she said this year
that she expects Google's cloud business
to overtake Amazon's by 2022 Wow there's
an entity that made the list but it's
not a specific person Russian botnet
tell us about their their achievements
yeah we had we had fun with this one so
if you recall about a year ago right
after President Trump was elected Mark
Zuckerberg came out and said that it was
a crazy idea that there had been any
sort of fake dudes influencing the
election well a year later what we
learned in congressional testimony is
that there are actually or 126 million
people that saw some form of fake news
connected to Russian botnets so they
obviously had a huge influence and we're
still trying to actually figure out
exactly what that influence is right
there our administration officials on
the list that maybe not ones you thought
would be on the list Scott Pruett the
EPA Administrator is one of them why
right so as we've been having these
discussions all year about what
accomplishments is the Trump
administration have quietly at over at
the EPA Scott Pruett has basically been
dismantling Obama era regulations what
we saw happen this year is really that
this is a man who spent his entire
career sort of fighting the EPA from the
outside and now he's on the inside and
really trying to repeal a lot of what
came to fruition over the last
administration big changes yeah it's a
fascinating list the Bloomberg 50 Brett
vigan thanks so much for being with us
this morning yeah